le fils au basket chez peines c'est tout
ça est bien le fils de pascal zentz
maintenant c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'attendre d'eux on arrête tout
l'arc nom alors je comprend pas le
projet comment tu t'appelles loucas
louca déjà tu va redescendre de deux
étages seulement tu fais quoi dans
l'habitude l'est pas dans la coiffure
ration marc dosch aux sports dans le
sport c'est quoi tu va remplacer kelly
ce soir quoi c'est que mon fils ne jure
sur la tête bien sûr non
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai qu'être sens il amusé
l'oncle sam abal à chiens
c'est fréquent je me plais pas kevin
déjà quel est ton projet capillaires et
ça y est tu veux pas que je coupe tout
de suite et je veux moi oh non
oui déjà mon père ouais c'est pas finir
comme ça c'est super ce témoin 30 ans 30
offerts et les perdre au but
il est hyper bové le mot mais je profite
vois tu profites un soûlard là je vais
te dire être tu profites un peu trop là
franchement là là frérot mais en
franchement tu devrais mes toiles comme
ici on dira taper mais il faut que je
raccourcis sait si non tu veux pas alors
je te fais un dégradé progressif fondu
derrière moi et sénégalais est mauvais
une musique sans déconner on dirait que
je suis dans un sens la boîte à mèche
bonjour tu vois toi toi en fait il faut
que tu chiffonne taux de cheveux tu vas
voir la baisse modérée
sur la tête de ma mère c'est beaucoup
mieux comme ça sur ma vie
[Applaudissements]
on écrire enfin on peut bosser de merde
battant l'assistanat on fait un
piquetage avec un fondu attends je fais
rien pour l'inspecter du pic pic et pic
et pic et il sait tout faire
[Applaudissements]
on va se retrouver dans un instant je
devais avoir cinq minutes pour faire de
toi un des plus beaux gosses de ces
quinze dernières années
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je ne cautionne pas non mais regardez
comme il est pas bon temps
magnifique mais il sent pas plus beau
[Applaudissements]
des 100 fois plus au but sont pas pas
franchement c'est pas mal alors à couper
sur les côtés tu vas aller tu vas aller
te finir ministre et je veux le voir
dans 5 minutes coiffure prête je vais
faire dégrader progressivement fait
c'est parce que notre mais pas les
toucher à tout et comme moi je me fasse
un très bon
[Applaudissements]
tu va trahir la montre est annoncé mort
scénique assez bien non c'est très très
bien
non mais ça va pas du tout c'est pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est bon
selon pascal schepens c'est tout ça est
bien le fils de pascal zentz maintenant
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi faire ça tu es content
bouchons ouais je l'avais dit je
m'estime d'où la suite si ça te va y
perdre cet automne avec nous
[Musique]